comme vous le savez tous la liaison lyon
turin est l'un des méga projet européen
d'infrastructures de transport cette
saison est composé d'un tunnel
transfrontalier de 57 km de long est
d'environ 150 km de lignes nouvelles
il s'agit d'un projet ancien entériné en
1994 par le conseil européen
depuis lors quatre accords entre la
france et l'italie ont été signés sur ce
sujet la loi d'orientation des mobilités
a précisé que l'état confirme son
engagement dans la réalisation de la
liaison ferroviaire international fret
et voyageurs reliant turin et une
dizaine de kilomètres du tunnel de base
ont été creusés
pourriez-vous d'ailleurs nous faire un
point d'avancement ce président sur ce
chantier
le lyon turin a vocation à s'inscrire
dans le corridor méditerranéen du réseau
de transport européen
il poursuit un triple objectif
son ambition est d'abord d'assurer à un
report modal vers le rail du fret mais
aussi des voyageurs et de réduire le
temps de trajet entre lyon et turin
cet égard pourriez vous revenir sur la
ligne de la maurienne
il relie déjà la région rhône alpes à la
frontière italienne et sur les raisons
qui ont conduit à privilégier la
réalisation d'une nouvelle ligne le
projet vise ensuite à sécuriser les
transports dans les alpes franco
italiennes
après les drames que nous avons connu
dans les tunnels du mont blanc 1999 et
de fréjus en 2005
l'objectif est enfin de réduire les
émissions polluantes et les nuisances
sonores sur ce trajet sur ce dernier
point pourriez vous nous en dire plus
sur l'estimation de l'impact
environnemental du projet avant de vous
laisser la parole je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur trois points d'abord
pourriez vous nous éclairer sur le
calendrier du projet l'objectif de mise
en service en 2030 et il demain tenus
la ministre italienne des transports a
annoncé en décembre dernier que 2032
était une hypothèse plus raisonnable
qu'en pensez vous en outre dans son
rapport de juin dernier la cour des
comptes européenne estimé que la liaison
ne serait probablement pas prêt de 10 il
a estimé que le chantier connaissait un
important retard qu'elle chiffre à 15
années
ensuite nous souhaiterions bénéficier de
votre éclairage sur le financement du
projet le protocole additionnel de mars
2016 fixe le coût de la section
transfrontalière à 8,3 milliards d'euros
là aussi la cour des comptes européenne
a pointé dans son apport d'importants
dérapage sur le plan budgétaire avec une
augmentation des coûts qui atteindrait
85 % en est-il d'après vous pouvez vous
rappeler les par respectivement prise en
charge par la france l'italie et l'union
européenne tant pour le tunnel de base
que pour les voies d'accès sur ce
dernier point en particulier l'union
européenne s'est dite prête à financer à
55% des voies d'accès comment cette
nouvelle at elle été accueillie côté
français on fait mais enfin ma dernière
question porte sur les critiques dont le
projet avait dû faire l'objet
la cour des comptes dans un référé
d'attin de 2012 en formule est incertain
on va savoir la faible rentabilité socio
économique du projet
la révision à la baisse des prévisions
du trafic les incertitudes en matière de
financement et l'insuffisant pilotage de
l'opération
comment avez-vous réagi face à ces
observations toutes les difficultés
soulevées il ya près de dix ans ont
elles été réglé je vous cède désormais
la parole pour une dizaine de minutes
merci monsieur le président merci de
saluer et sur le bouton et de passer
quelques instants avec vous pour parler
de ceux de ce projet voilà sur lequel je
suis engagée depuis longtemps vous avez
rappelé que c'est une longue histoire
déjà ce projet et pour ma part c'est en
2001 que pu participer à l'étape
vraiment très importante avec le
ministre jean claude gayssot
quelques temps après l'accident du
tunnel du mont blanc et où la france
pensait toute l'europe
on priait conscience du problème majeur
que représente et la circulation des
poids lourds dans les traversées alpines
alors je vais pas refaire l'histoire
mais peut être qu'on crée en quelques
minutes reprendre très précisément les
points que vous avez vous avez cités
il ya eu donc une longue période
d'études de travaux de reconnaissance
d'exploration géologique
certains ont trouvé trop longue pour ma
part je pense qu'on a eu raison de
prendre du temps pour réussir et de voir
comment cette montagne était constituée
et comment on pouvait réaliser cet
ouvrage une partie ce délai a été due
aux difficultés italiennes que tout le
monde a en tête et aux violences
opposition qui se sont manifestés dans
la vallée de suse et qui a obligé à
reprendre le projet se chier maintenant
surmonter
quoique il ya encore peu de temps on
s'interrogeait sur l'attitude de nos
amis italiens on peut dire que
maintenant on est rentré dans une phase
d'abord définitive puisque après cette
période d'étude des travaux de
reconnaissance
on est rentré dans son appel les travaux
définitifs c'est à dire le creusement du
tunnel lui-même du tunnel principal on
est en train de préparer les appels
d'offres pour attribuer les marchés de
réalisation du tunnel proprement dit
donc après cette longue histoire
d'études
après ces péripéties et parfois ces
questions sur le projet ou sur son
opportunité
on est maintenant dans une dans une
phase de réalisation massive puisque ces
appels d'offres pour le tunnel lui-même
représente un engagement de l'ordre de 4
milliards d'euros
on reviendra près sur les aspects
financiers alors deuxième élément
pourquoi une nouvelle ligne alors vous
avez 17 il appartient effectivement au
réseau européen l'europe depuis
longtemps veut réaliser un réseau
ferroviaire de grande capacité à
l'échelle européenne
structuré autour de neuf corridor nous
sommes sur le corridor sud qu'on appelle
méditerranée qui va du sud de l'espagne
l'est de l'europe
ce corridor ensuite passez par
montpellier si je peux dire remonte vers
lyon traverse les alpes et continue vers
l'état liées et vers l'est
donc nous sommes sur ce corridor
européen volonté d'un réseau européen de
grande capacité pouvant traiter et le
fret et les voyageurs alors il existe
déjà une ligne bien entendu qui va de
lyon le tunnel du fréjus et qui
redescend vers vers turin et la question
était souvent débattu pour quoi faire
une nouvelle ligne coûteuse et un
nouveau tunnel alors qu' il existe une
ligne dite historique
cette ligne date notamment le tunnel du
fréjus qui même date de 1871 et elles
nous ont fêté année le 150e anniversaire
d anniversaire de ce funeste alors
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur
cette histoire hic j'ai eu l'occasion
mauvaise d'ailleurs d'y travailler quand
j'étais président de réseau ferré de
france pour l'améliorer elle ne peut pas
répondre aux objectifs alors ça je pense
que ce sujet devrait être pour jédir
conclu de manière claire pourquoi est ce
qu'elle ne peut pas répondre aux
objectifs de croissance du trafic de
fret il ya deux raisons à cela il ya une
raison que c'est une ligne
deux-montagnes et donc le train devant
monter la cote
il faut couper le train en deux il peut
pas faire plus de 600 tonnes il faut au
moins deux locomotives et parfois trois
ce qui est coûteux prend du temps et
n'est pas du tout efficace part
conséquente
première raison la ligne deux montagnes
ne permet pas de faire du trafic à
grande capacité à bonne vitesse pour le
fret
deuxième raison le tunnel lui-même le
tunnel historique et1 tunnels monotubes
il a donc 150 ans il est constitué d'un
seul tube
or les règles européennes maintenant
font obstacle à ce que l'on exploite un
tunnel fret avec des trains de grande
capacité
avec un seul tube et donc il faut
maintenant que les tunnels qui est font
que passer du trafic fret en abondance
soit structurée sur deux tubes comme
l'est déjà le tunnel sous la manche on
peut dire que ce qu'on construit
aujourd'hui sous les alpes est
exactement l'équivalent du tunnel sous
la manche sous la manche deux tubes
indépendant à voie unique qui permette
aux trains de ne pas se croiser à
l'intérieur du tunnel avec des
possibilités de passage d'un tunnel à
l'autre si un train accidenté dans un
tunnel ont fait sortir les gens ils
passent sur notre tunnel et ils peuvent
se sortir donc ça veut dire que dans le
tenait à l'actuel on peut faire passer
qu'un train la fois dans un sens unique
on peut pas en mettre 2 donc la capacité
est très limité si vous ajoutez tout ça
le résultat c'est que la ligne
historique la haine actuelle peut faire
passer des trains peut se passer des
trains mais en très faible quantité il
ya aujourd'hui un trafic d'environ 3
millions de tonnes sur cette ligne alors
qu'il ya quelques années quand j'étais
rff ont dépassé les 10 millions de
tonnes
voilà donc je veux dire que ça ne peux
pas te papa
alors sur l'impact environnemental côté
négatif commençons par faire du négatif
évidemment chaque fois que l'on fait des
travaux et notamment des travaux
importants dans la montagne
voilà on pourrait du co2 et donc il ya
un bilan négatif pour commencer et puis
après vous avez un bilan un résultat
positif c'est que vous supprimez des
camions qui passait avant par les
autoroutes et les les tunnels
autoroutiers et vous les mettez sur le
train alors nous l'objectif est très
simple c'est de faire comme les suisses
aujourd'hui 8% du trafic pas sur le
train et plus de 90% sur la route
voilà les suisses sont arrivés à plus de
60% sur le train alors que nous sommes à
huit et l'objectif donc pour faire
peut-être un peu moins bien que serait
d'atteindre près de 50% de report modal
et donc on supprimera des camions la
capacité serait de faire passer un
million de camions sur les trains plutôt
que sur la route et on estime que ça
devrait faire une économie de 1 million
de co2 alors du coup on à prendre un
certain nombre d'années d'abord on
produit des nuisances environnementales
en faisant le chantier et puis après on
redresse la situation parce qu'on
supprime des camions et on a un moyen de
transport ferroviaire qui est évidemment
plus performant alors on peut discuter
indéfiniment pour savoir au bout de
combien d'années le bidon redeviendra
positif
moi je prends pas position je suis pas
le père je vois simplement que mon sushi
c'est tout simplement dans un premier
temps de réduire les nuisances
environnementales du chantier et puis de
faire en sorte que quand le tunnel sera
ouvert le plus vite possible on met les
camions sur les trains alors c'est un
peu sa pelisse ce que je dis mais je
pense que ça correspond bien à une
réalité
donc nous nous efforçons de travailler
beaucoup sur les questions
d'environnement à l'occasion du chantier
et nous espérons qu'avec les opérateurs
ferroviaires et les états ça dépend pas
que de nous bien sûr le tunnel sera
exploité le plus possible et que
notamment les autoroutes ferroviaires
c'est à dire les passages des camions
sur les trains permettra d'en tirer le
meilleur parti alors je viens au
calendrier
l'objectif fixé par les financeurs
c'est à dire l'europe principal
financeur 40 % l'italie et la france
l'objectif c'est 2030 alors il était dit
qu'on n'y arriverait pas moi je ne
ces patients n'y arrivera ou pas on
essaie de tenir ce calendrier
le calendrier est tendue on est en train
de prendre un peu de retard parce que la
crise sanitaire créé des difficultés ne
bloque pas le chantier mais crée des
difficultés ministre italienne a dit je
pourrais bien qu'on dépasse 2032 nous
actuellement nous restons sur 2030
pourquoi parce que s'il ya un contrat
qui lie l'europe les deux états et nous
et que dans ce contrat aujourd'hui
qu'ils apportent les financements il ya
un objectif 2030
notre devoir c'est faire tout ce qu'on
peut pour respecter l'objectif l'année
prochaine enfin plutôt en fin de 2013
on va négocier le nouveau contrat de
financement avec l'europe secteur
prépare le financement des projets à
venir pour les années qui viennent
il ya eu discussion difficile sur le
budget européen et nous nous préparons a
commencé avec vous c'est la négociation
pour les années qui viennent on
rediscutera à ce moment-là du calendrier
faut-il garder 2030
faut-il faut-il corrigé de 2 années ce
programme je laisse les responsables de
trois entités europe et l italie et
france
prendre en considération les difficultés
que nous avons pu avoir elles ne sont
pas énormes mais elles sont réelles et
faut-il ou pas ajustés aux justiciables
ans qui est un arbitrage à faire entre
le calendrier le coup si vous augmentez
le nombre de tunneliers vous aller plus
vite mais ça coûte plus cher donc il ya
un arbitrage à faire respecter le
calendrier respecté le coup et trouver
un point d'équilibré entre les deux ce
qui sera discuté dans le courant de
cette année 2001 était alors le le le
financement dont 8 milliards vous avez
rappelé le chiffre 8 milliards 3
finances est donc actuellement 40% pour
l'europe 30 5% pour l'italie 25 % pour
la france je note au passage que
l'italie finance davantage le projet que
nous est comme ça que ça a été négocié
enfin il faut respecter le fait que
l'italie a tout même une part de
financement plus importante
alors on a dit beaucoup de choses sur le
projet le projet est estimé à 8
milliards 3 depuis que nous l'avons
lancée il y avait précédemment peut-être
d'autres scénarios qui avait été
envisagé mais le projet n'a pas changé
d'estimation depuis que nous l'avons
vous avez rappelé les dates 2000 2012
les états se mettent d'accord sur la
manière de faire si je puis dire et sur
la création du promoteur 2015 l'ensemble
projet avec une estimation est fixé à ce
moment-là 2003 nous n'en avons pas
changé
est-ce qu'on tiendra jusqu'au bout je
fais pas de pronostic
on fait tout ce que l'on peut pour
maintenir ce chiffre mais il n'est pas
juste de dire que le projet a flambé si
je peux dire nous en sommes nous en tout
cas depuis 2015 au même niveau des
estimations là aussi il faut faire
attention que nous projetons nous
parlons là pour ce montant-là du tunnel
lui-même dont nous sommes chargés au
delà du tunnel il ya les accès côté
italie il ya les excès côté france ce
sont deux autres projets on pourrait
revenir si vous voulez évidemment
l'objectif c'est aménager l'ensemble
itinéraire lyon turin
mais quand on parle de notre estimation
nous ne parlons que du tunnel on
reviendra peut-être sur la question des
désaxés où je peux vraiment en dire un
mot
dès maintenant donc nous nous nous
société binational tel tu
franco-italienne 50/50 dirigé et
contrôlé par les états totalement public
ça c'est tout à fait clair nous sommes
chargés du tunnel mais il doit y avoir
une coordination sur l'ensemble de
l'itinéraire
parce que si le tunnel est finie mettant
vos envies en 2030 avec ses
caractéristiques très performant je
rappelle qu'il faut faire passer les
trains de voyageurs à 220 km heure dans
le tunnel et les trains de fret à 120
kilomètres/heure alors si vous êtes
passé par là dans le train actuel vous
voyez que évidemment on n'en est pas à
cette vitesse là puisque monte à côte
aux environs de 30 ou 40 km heure et est
pas plus donc si on finit le tunnel et
qu'on n'a pas aménagé des accès on va
voir quelque chose qui n'a pas beaucoup
de chance puisqu'on ne pourra pas
utiliser les capacités du tunnel et on
bloquera sur la partie accès donc il ya
bien un problème global on peut pas dire
qu'on se contente du tunnel donc nous
nous soutenons les projets d'aménagement
des voies d'accès ceux ci ont fait
l'objet de discussions difficiles c'est
qu'ils connaissent la région le savent
bien pour savoir qui on commence par
lyon / va jusqu à champéry si on passe
jeu si on passe pas à chambrer
ceci n'est pas de notre compétence mais
nous avons un intérêt évident à ce que
ce projet des voies d'accès soient
correctement conduit l'europe est sur
cette ligne là au point que alors qu'au
départ ne parlait pas des voies d'accès
elle a offert sa contribution pour
financer les voies d'accès comme elle
finance le tunnel et donc nous avons
nous à clichy très favorablement cette
proposition et nous espérons que cela
permettra d'accélérer l'aménagement des
voies d'accès la partie italienne est
déjà réglé donc le projet beaucoup plus
simple que chez nous est déjà prêt et
côté italien
la partie française est plus difficile
elle est plus longue et plus coûteuse et
donc les plus discutés on va dire au
départ après la loi d'orientation
la france avait dit on va attendre que
les tunnels soit finie on verra ce qu'il
faut faire des accès l'inconvénient
c'est que ça renvoie évidemment une date
très lointaine l'aménagement des accès
et que ceci va sans doute être contestés
c'est déjà contesté par l'europe et qui
dit nous on ne peut pas accepter qu'on
fait le tunnel d'abord et qu'on regarde
ce que ça donne pour commencer les accès
après 2035
donc ça je suis sûr que cette position
n'a pas été acceptée du coup la france a
évolué et donc nous travaillons en ce
moment partenariat avec celle de ses
frais zoé est piloté par le préfet va la
possibilité d'avoir un programme phase
et d'aménagement plus rapide quant aux
dernières critiques vous évoquiez sur la
je termine d'ailleurs pour dire que
l'europe tient tellement à ce projet que
la commission a fait savoir qu'elle
prouve qu'elle souhaitait pour les
prochains programmes donc les années qui
viennent
qu'elle souhaitait monter de 40 à 50%
son financement et qu elle était même
prêt à ajouter 5 % de plus si je peux
dire de bonus parce que bruxelles estime
que notre société est une société
binational suffisamment européenne si je
puis dire pour être considéré comme un
bon élève et donc elle veut nous
apporter 5 % de plus ce qu'il pouvait
porter à 55 % la contribution européenne
ce qui est exceptionnel je ne connais
pas beaucoup d'autres projets où
l'europe s'est engagée à ce point donc
on peut dire au passage que ce projet a
une dimension européenne très forte et
qu'on peut dire qui l'acheminé jusque
aujourd'hui y compris à travers des
péripéties où des crises il a cheminé
parce que l'europe a sur ce sujet
une volonté très forte détermination
totale de le mener à son terme
alors les critiques qui ont été faites
oui je les connais celle de la cour des
comptes pas la première fois que la cour
des comptes fait des critiques sur des
projets souvent d'ailleurs tout à fait
justifié en l'occurrence la notion de
rentabilité telles qu'elles étaient
calculés il ya eu 8 8 évaluation de
rentabilité sur ce projet toute
différente suivant tous les fêtes une
année de crise où le trafic routier
s'arrête ou bien à une année de
croissance où le trafic routier augmente
vous avez des résultats évidemment
différent nous on a simplement constaté
que si vous raisonnez sur un très long
terme c'est à dire si vous accepter
l'idée que cet ouvrage est fait pour
durer cent ans tout le monde se trompe
dans ses évaluations mais au bout de
cent ans ça change plus grand chose et
je vais dire si vous des quais et vous
dépassez vous vous décalez de 10 15 ans
ou 20 ans votre estimation sur l'échelle
de 100 ans à la halle afin d'aider du
temps si je puis dire vous vous avez les
lacs sont pas très différents donc moi
je ne prends pas position sur ces
questions de rentabilité
elles ont été discutés partager critiqué
et puis les responsables décideurs
politiques de nos états des parlements
et de bruxelles ont décidé qu'il fallait
le faire donc nous essayons de le faire
le mieux possible et on en revient à la
notion du du pilotage
encore une fois vous elle considère que
nous sommes plutôt bons élèves
puisqu'ils veulent nous apporter 5 % de
plus notre société binational alors
d'abord alain caractère totalement
public c'est une condition déjà que j'ai
vu me moi même pour y participer et
surtout que j'ai vécu à peu près
l'expérience du ciel sous la manche
puisque j'étais au port de dunkerque à
ce moment-là pense que tout le monde a
en mémoire à la fois la réussite
technique du tunnel sous la manche et le
désastre financier que ça que ça a pu
être
personne n'a oublié donc le choix qui a
été fait dès le départ c'est de dire
cette affaire n'a pas de caractère privé
elle est totalement publique elle est
voulue par les états et par bruxelles
veut être assumée par les états et par
bruxelles
nous avons des actionnaires publics 100%
public maintenant la société binational
franco italienne est une organisation
assez original n'a pas tellement que ça
dans le secteur public donc surtout que
moi même si j'appliquais 2
de nombreuses années voilà je trouve que
ceci demande quelques efforts
d'adaptation on va dire culturel entre
les équipes italiennes les équipes
françaises mais je suis témoin moi même
que si on fait cet effort d'acceptation
des différences ça donne des résultats
très fructueux car il ya des deux côtés
des gens qui ont des grandes compétences
par des grandes qualités sont les maires
bon ordre de marche ça peut donner de
bons résultats comme moi même je suis
témoin que c'est le cas et que nous
avons jusqu'à présent conduit fait
avancer ce projet dans des conditions
que l'on n'a pas en tout cas j'estime
satisfaisant ne suis pas pro grand chose
mais ne pense que nos équipes
fonctionnent de très bien j'avoue
d'ailleurs que les entreprises qui font
les chantiers sont pratiquement toujours
multinationales tous les marchés que
nous attribuons je parle de marché un
peu importants sont attribués à des
groupements pendant lequel vous avez des
français des italiens est souvent des
suisses et que ces entreprises associent
des équipes de nationalités différentes
et que ça marche bien elles sont souvent
originaires des territoires prochain
donc souvent région rhône-alpes et
piémont
donc ce sont des gens un peu frontaliers
ayant peut-être plus de capacité à
s'adapter mais je constate que sur les
chantiers dont vous avez des personnes
de ces différentes origines et qu'elle
travaille très bien ensemble et jusqu'à
présent tous nos chantiers se sont
passés dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
voilà on pourra aborder d'autres sujets
si vous voulez notamment un sujet auquel
on est très très attentif de sujet on
reviendra sur les questions
d'environnement voudrait sans doute des
questions à poser sur ce thème
et puis auch et la question de
l'intégrité nous avons mis en place un
dispositif de contrôle extrêmement
strict et notamment pour essayer de
prévenir tout risque d'intrusion de la
mafia voilà je m'arrête sur cette note
qui peut-être pas la plus la plus
sympathique
merci monsieur le président donc je vais
laisser la parole à rémy pointereau
rapporteur de la mission d'information
relative au transport de marchandises
face aux impératifs environnementaux et
l'issue à l'ensemble de nos collègues
idéaux sollicités merci monsieur le
président d'abord monsieur le directeur
président du mesnil très heureux
vous soyez missionné pour cette
présidence de la société du tunnel aura
le pain lyon turin parce que vous
connaissez parfaitement le réseau
ferroviaire français en ayant été
directeur général de rff et j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous rencontrer à
plusieurs reprises pour un sujet qui
nous est cher mais j'en dirais quelques
mots tout à l'heure c'est vrai que notre
commission a créé cette mission
d'information relative au transport de
marchandises face aux impératifs
environnementaux et nous sommes co
rapporteur avec ma collègue nicole
bonnefoy
nous avons entendu au cours de nos
auditions les discos parfois
contradictoires sur l'avenir du fret
ferroviaire certains y croient ils
croient beaucoup et en visant un
doublement de la part du ferroviaire
c'est à dire le passé de 2,9 à 18% d'ici
et puis d'autres qui estiment au
contraire qu'il faut renoncer à cette
chimère du report modal le projet du
lyon turin est heureusement fondée sur
la première hypothèse d' augmenter cette
part du ferroviaire du fret ferroviaire
pourriez-vous nous dire nous en dire
plus sur les prévisions de trafic sur
cette liaison ferroviaire est d'après
vous quels sont les leviers pour
favoriser davantage encore le report
modal de la route vers le faire savoir
les aides à d'exploitation la qualité de
service et puis j'aurai une question
subsidiaire
monsieur monsieur le président pouvons
nous espérer que le lyon-turin
augmentent suffisamment le trafic de la
lgv paris-lyon
pour obtenir cette fameuse ligne pau khl
il fait qui sert d'aménagement du
territoire et de doublement même temps
de la ligne paris lyon qui serait un
vrai projet d'aménagement du territoire
mais qui permettrait aussi peut-être de
soulager cette ligne parisien qui je
l'espère va augmenter son trafic si on
fait 1 1 lyon turin
donc voilà mai
les questions que je souhaitais vous
vous posez monsieur le président le
président b et merci retrouvez aussi
après quelques souvenirs communs alors
sur les prévisions de trafic et la
question du report modal un tout petit
peu d'histoire
quand le projet a été lancé il y avait
précédemment d'intention de la sncf
développer un réseau tgv est européen
j'étais du tout tgv on ne parlait que de
ça quand les états ont repris en main si
je peux dire le projet quand l'europe
l'a inscrit dans un projet de réseau
européen
la composante la composante fret est
devenue dominante je je je dis pas que
on a oublié les voyageurs puisque notre
tunnel sera mixte et qu'il s'agit bien
de traiter les voyageurs et notamment
sur thur à bilan mais aussi mais surtout
le fret
donc c'est un projet demi entre eux
alors évidemment si on pense que le fret
ferroviaire n'a pas d'avenir
et puis elle n'a pas d'intérêt là et je
pense qu'effectivement il faut arrêter
le projet oui parce que le projet ne
peut pas se défendre
de mon point de vue je parle très
librement en toute transparence
le problème ne peut pas se défendre si
vous avez uniquement une perspective de
trafic voyageur il ya bien d'autres
projets voyageurs qui sont plus urgent
est plus utile en france celui que vous
évoquez parmi bien d'autres encore donc
j'ai des souvenirs là de réseau ferré de
france est effectivement n'est pas c'est
pas l'ombre d'un doute là dessus si ce
projet est réservé aux voyageurs il n'a
pas d'intérêt il faut l'arrêter il faut
concentrer tous nos efforts sur d autres
projets qui restent encore à faire sur
le réseau français donc c'est un sujet
fret donc il n'a d'intérêt que si on
pense ou si on croit que le report modal
c'est à dire la reprise
roland du trafic fret est possible et
nécessaire possible et nécessaire
nécessaire je pense que tout le monde
voit bien dans l'intérêt environnemental
à l'échelle de l'europe et pas
uniquement française d'autres le feront
ils le font mieux que nous est ce que
c'est possible il ya quelques conditions
là il faut reconnaître qu'on part avec
un handicap terrible on est parmi les
projets les pays
européens où le fret est descendu au
plus bas donc on peut pas être très
fiers de la situation dans laquelle on
est aujourd'hui alors si on dit que on
peut pas s'en sortir qu'on peut pas
faire mieux qu il faut se contenter du
réseau autoroutier c'est vrai on veut
renoncer
est-ce que c'est impossible moi je ne
crois pas que ce soit impossible alors
je vous donnerai peut-être de deux
arguments je trouve que moi j'ai été
très impressionné dans les années 2000
quand j'étais au ministère par ce qui
s'est passé en suisse et que évidemment
quand on est dans la région rhône alpes
en particulier on regarde de près ce que
font nos voisins qui sont des gens
plutôt rationnel qui s'affrontaient qui
font les choses plutôt bien ils ensemble
des défauts 6 mai bref ils ont une
situation de trafic difficile totalement
ou presque totalement alpines et ils ont
fait des choix qui consiste à dire on
refuse le laisser aller du trophée du
transport routier et on fait ce qu'il
faut pour faire du report modal fait ce
qu'il faut ça veut dire deux choses
investir pour avoir des infrastructures
performantes pour le fret ferroviaire et
deuxièmement réguler le trafic routier
c'est à dire au faire payer et donc ils
ont fait cette politique là avec un
soutien populaire très fort et ça
donnait des résultats absolument
spectaculaire ils ont construit deux
grands tunnels nord-sud le symbole
thalberg qui sont déjà finies alors que
nous commençons le nôtre et qui ont les
mêmes caractéristiques que notre des
tunnels sous les alpes c'est très
compliqué c'est très coûteux ça ils font
50 km donc qui sont dans les mêmes
difficultés que nous ils ont fait ils
ont fait tout seul
ils ont payé ils sont riches ils ont
payé et ils ont maintenant puis les deux
tiers du trafic qui passe sur la voie
ferrée donc moi je pense que ce qui a
été fait en suisse relax je pense de la
même logique dé les mêmes objectifs de
lutte contre la pollution
de même l'objectif de développement
ferroviaire et des mêmes difficultés et
le résultat ils ont donc je veux dit
après tout pourquoi est ce que nous on
ne peut pas faire la même chose qu'est
ce qui fait que c'est possible pour la
suisse et c'est pas possible pour la
crainte alors cela dit ça ne suffit pas
parce que
on pense qu'on peut arriver à faire
d'excusés elle comme eux que l'on pense
être aussi capable que surtout si
l'europe nous a aidé à financer et qu'on
doit pouvoir y arriver sur le plan
financier en revanche pour que le trafic
fret marche
il ya d'autres conditions à remplir il
ne suffit pas de faire un magnifique
tunnel il faut empire d'autres
conditions vous avez évoqué qualité de
service ça c'est sûr il faut qu'il y ait
des sillons comme disent les les
spécialistes c'est à dire qu'une fois
que le train a traversé les lacs il faut
qu'il arrive à lyon il faut qu'il passe
à lyon il faut qu'ils puissent ensuite
remonter vers le nord et que le réseau
soit géré pour que les sillons réservés
au trafic de marchandises soit de bonne
qualité c'est à dire que on est les
mêmes exigences de fiabilité de sécurité
pour le fret pour les voyageurs je
connaissais bien tout ça quand il ya des
travaux
les trains de fret ne passe pas quand et
des mouvements sociaux des trains de
fret ne passe pas il n'y a pas
d'engagement de qualité de service et
donc il ya de nombreuses difficultés sur
le réseau qu'il faut traiter en même
temps donc cette affaire ne marche que
s'il ya une volonté de report modal fois
qu'elle est quand même largement partagé
même si certains pensent que ce n'est
plus la peine de faire sa volonté de
faire du report modal et deuxièmement
effort national avec des moyens
financiers des investissements sur le
réseau et des choix de priorités réservé
au trafic de marchandises pour coup
considère le trafic de marchandises a
les mêmes exigences de qualité ici
qu'ailleurs
ici en france que dans les autres pays
et quand on va en suisse contournant
même en italie du nord on est étonné de
voir la manière dont les trafics de
marchandises sont traités en qu'un
exemple le suivi informatique des trains
de marchandises pour que tout le monde
sache où ils train à quelle heure il
arrive et si le lokomotiv de bons
endroits
tout ceci n'est pas encore au point
progresse mais n'est pas encore au point
et on a des tgv ultra performant sur le
plan technique en des trains de
marchandises
cette année de retard voilà donc je
pense qu'il faut travailler sur tous ses
registres à la fois
mais l'idée que ce report modal mais
n'est plus opportun n'est plus possible
et et n'est plus un projet commun à tous
moi personnellement me choque
profondément
alors sur le paris-lyon là je suis plus
- de moins capables en tout cas de vous
répondre
il n'y a pas de doute donc le d'abord
une raison sur le corridor à et
l'attention de vos chaises pour
l'espagne passée par la ligue du sud
donc montpellier vont monter vers lyon
et vont traverser les alpes
donc le col le prénom n'est pas dans le
dans le corridor sur lequel nous
travaillons avec l'aide de cela dit
évidemment là le raccourcissement
considérable des zélés devrait augmenter
les liaisons sur turin et donc paris
lyon turin milan devrait se développer
on va gagner 2 heures donc c'est quand
même c'est quand même très très très
substantielle et va contribuer ou
devrait contribuer à renforcer le trafic
donc le sujet de paris-lyon du coup j'ai
dire ne doit être réfléchie et est
conduit en tenant compte de cette
perspective de croissance du trafic
italien pour pour dire les choses
simplement
alors après je ne sais pas où je ne sais
plus où on est le le projet de
doublement sur lequel j'avais travaillé
en son temps vous vous rappelez avec je
crois quand même des progrès techniques
qui doivent permettre que la ligne
actuelle puisse être encore un peu plus
densifiées 1 c'est à dire que
l'amélioration des outils de
signalisation permet de resserrer un peu
les trains mais ensuite
alors après moi je ne sais plus comment
le trafic tgv va évoluer dans le monde
qui change si vite autour de nous mais
je pense que la question reste posée que
ça sera de toute façon un axe essentiel
du réseau national sur lequel va se
concentrer énormément de trafic de
voyageurs
même s'il ya en ce moment la crise que
nous connaissons de toute façon le
paris-lyon va rester juliel la flèche de
notre réseau national et si on ajoute en
plus les trafics italien puisque vous
savez qu'actuellement sur le pari turin
en fait on on prend l'avion quand ma
main il ya très peu de personnes qui
prennent le train c'est trop long donc
là on va gagner 2 heures lyon turin là
ce sera le mans deux villes qui vont
vivre avec des navettes de cas lancement
avec des relations je suis d'autre que
moi sont plus compétents pour en parler
mais je pense que cette proximité
de ces deux grandes villes devraient
conduire un grand développement et de
développement trafic et bien je mets
paris dedans je mets paris de temps
voilà merci on va prendre une série de
questions j'ai donné la parole à
monsieur demi puis à madame fille léa
monsieur blanc monsieur 2000 merci
monsieur le président merci je suis ni
pour votre exposé clair et sans langue
de bois
j'ai deux questions à vous poser si les
objectifs de ce projet sont louables
vous l'avez dit le projet lyon turin
soulève de nombreuses critiques
notamment quant à sa rentabilité
les prévisions d'évolution de trafic
passagers et marchandises font l'objet
de désaccords tout comme d'ailleurs son
coût écologique
alors au delà de ses critiques qu'en est
il des toutes dernières estimations de
trafic passagers et marchandises pour
assurer la rentabilité économique et la
rentabilité environ table
environnemental de ce projet c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
tout comme le merveilleux projet de
canal seine nord europe
le projet de ligne lyon turin a été
retenu par la commission européenne dans
le cadre du est mieux du mécanisme pour
l'interconnexion en europe ce qui a
permis et vous l'avez dit dans votre
exposé d'obtenir un financement
merveilleux de 40% par par l'union
européenne en plus de ce fonds européens
allez vous bénéficiez ou souhaitez-vous
bénéficier du plan de relance européen
vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué le fait
que vous aviez booster votre financement
à 50 % vous allez même parler d'un bonus
supplémentaire de 5%
je suis pas sûr que la terminologie
bonus existent sur le plan budgétaire
donc était ce une façon de dire que vous
avez sollicité ce fameux plan de relance
européen
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président également ma
question rejoint les interrogations de
monsieur cointreau et de monsieur
dominique anton quant au report modal
en effet vous avez répondu à monsieur
point trop en évoquant une comparaison
avec la suisse est également les
conditions à remplir pour que ce report
modal s'effectue effectivement en france
mais que vous êtes de mon point de vue
comme le disait monsieur de mini resté
assez flou sur les perspectives
effective sur les chiffres est ce que
vous dites disposer aujourd'hui de
chiffres stabilisé par rapport à ce
report modal deuxième questionnements
qui rejoint des questionnements plus
anciens de monsieur aspar et de moi même
sur un rapport sur les ports français
nous nous posions déjà la question à ce
moment là de sa loi si l'aménagement
fassi le tunnel puces les aménagements
qui pourraient se faire sur l'axé lyon
turin par la route est également le
canal seine-nord ne priviligié rillettes
pas à un flux vers le nord et vers les
ports du nord et au final est bien ce
ferez ces flux se ferait aux dépens des
ports français et en particulier de
marseille
en effet dans ce cadre là monsieur
vaspart s'intéresser particulièrement à
la présence chinoise dans les ports
italiens et à la question des routes de
la soie
et donc voilà nous avons nous avions
insisté pas beaucoup d'inquiétude pour
le port de marseille est ce que vous
savez réfléchi à ces questions et vous
pouvez nous donner votre sentiment à ce
propos si les jus donnée par monsieur
blanc merci monsieur le président
messieurs présents du mesnil ces
dossiers vous le savez est un dossier
absolument essentiel pour la région
vernal pour le développement de son
économie mais surtout pour son ouverture
internationale sachant que notre
histoire est tourné vers l'italie d'une
heure et que pour nous c'est une étape
nouvelle de ses rapports avec cette
grande région industrielle
qui dépend de cette vision nocturne un
mois j'ai deux questions à vous poser
vous l'avez parfaitement exprimé l'
europe accepte de financer aujourd'hui à
50% le tunnel de base peut-être y
rappelle un peu au delà demain mais sa
priorité c'est le transport fret ce
n'est pas le transport voyageurs dans
des questions environnementales pour des
questions économiques et surtout pour
son ouverture sur l'europe de l'est
à travers cette liaison sous les alpes
qui nous fait aujourd'hui défaut
et pour que le fret soit effectivement
au coeur de cet investissement
il faut que les voies d'accès au tunnel
de base soit améliorée et là il ya deux
opportunités la première c'est une ligne
directe entre lyon et saint martin
laporte à l'entrée du tunnel et la
deuxième opportunité qui est proposé par
la sncf c'est l'amélioration de la ligne
entre dijon et modane à travers à
travers sur les bords du lac du bourget
et traversant chambéry est-ce que sur ce
choix la société tels aps a pris une
position est clairement les élus
auvergnats rhônalpins ont donné priorité
et liaison directe entre lyon et saint
martin laporte
or le creusement des tunnels sous
chartreuse où bell d'hommes et le tunnel
du glandon et que cette interrogation
faut-il passer par chambéry ce qu'est ce
qui est un autre sujet et moi j'aimerais
connaître la position de tête sur ce
sujet deuxième question nous avons avec
l'italie une discussion sur les délais
et nous avons même un peu avec l'europe
qui envisage de prendre un acte
d'exécution pour s'assurer que ces
délais seront bien respectés selon la
société telles quelles sont les
décisions ou les actes précis que vous
attendez pour que ce délai de 2030 soit
respectée et que les craintes de la
ministre des transports italienne qui
dit mais tout ça va être portée en 2032
voire même au delà pour que ces craintes
soient levés quels sont les actes
juridiques
ancier diplomatique que vous attendez
pour le respect des délais et vous
laisse répondre j'ai plaisir d'apprendre
une autre série de comprendre la parole
oui alors sur la question dans ta vie tu
ai fait moi je
j'avoue ne sont pas capables de de dire
quelle est la courbe de trafic qui peut
justifier le le tunnel et si on s'écarte
de cette courbe n'est ce qu'il faut ne
plus le faire donc je regarde avec
beaucoup d'humilité ce qui s'est passé
il ya eu la crise financière de 2008 le
trafic a baissé
donc on a dit pas puisqu'il trafic
baisse le projet celui qui fit plus et
puis au bout de trois ans le trafic est
reparti à la croissance donc la ronde à
nouveau une situation difficile quel
sera le trafic finalement en 2020 2021
qu'elle qui résultera de la crise
actuelle
on voit bien la baisse de la croissance
économique incontestable
est ce que c'est une baisse durable est
ce qu'elle va reprendre d'entre 4 ans je
suis totalement incapable de faire ces
prévisions je considère que c'est pas
par moi allez faire c'est pas ma
compétence est pas ma responsabilité
donc moi je joue je pense qu'il faut que
tout le monde aborde avec beaucoup de
prudence à cette question là et ce n'est
pas parce que les chiffres donnent un
pourcentage de croissance de camions
qu'il faut conclure que forcément le
tunnel doit être fait ou pas fait je
pense qu'il faut faire ses études mais
que peut attendre de ces études qu'elle
dicte une décision qui me semble-t-il a
quand même beaucoup à un caractère
politique
voilà alors après évidemment on peut
aussi observer l'évolution du monde
vous avez parlé par exemple des trafics
de la chine
et puis des ports donc j'élargis un
petit peu le sujet
cet axe il a d'abord comme à terrell
facilitée si on fait un peu de
géographie les liens entre les deux
régions régions auvergne et rhône-alpes
et maintenant et piémont c'est sont deux
grandes régions économiques qui ont déjà
entre elles beaucoup de raisons de
multiplier leurs échanges de personnes
d'étudiants de touristes et de camions
et de marchandises donc cet itinéraire
là à cet avantage là si on élargit il
relie
espagne le sud de la france le nord de
l'italie et le sud de l'europe
donc cet ensemble la représente déjà un
potentiel économique qui n'est pas
négligeable
on estime que près 20% du pib qui
concernait directement par cet
itinéraire est donc même si globalement
il ya des périodes de crise voire de
récession économique se pose ce
territoire-là représente un potentiel
des changes important sans même parler
de ce qui peut se passer au delà par
exemple si les italiens veulent aller en
angleterre ils ont quelques intérêts
aussi où quelques possibilités de passer
par là pour aller vers la jambe retard
alors maintenant on va te dire avec le
bassiste ça peut-être moins d'intérêt
mais moi je ne sais pas et il y aura
toujours des camions sur l'angleterre
donc voilà donc je reste sur la prudence
et la réserve
je dis simplement que notre projet peut
faire passer un million de camions ça
c'est une chose tout à fait certaine
façon c'est la calculer notre projet
peut faire passer un million de camions
et donc que ça représente une part
significative des camions qui
aujourd'hui traverse les alpes par les
trois axes mont-blanc fréjus et
vintimille et que si on a en prend des
camions de ces trois axes qu'ils aillent
ensuite jusqu'au sud de l'espagne ou
plutôt jusqu'à lyon ou plutôt jusqu'à
dijon
de toute façon notre ouvrage permet de
les prendre et il les prendra si
l'ouvragé fait et si de part et d'autre
et ça fait le lien avec la question des
accès il trouve des itinéraires des
réseaux sur lesquels ils sont
suffisamment prioritaire pour passer
alors nous avons donc dans ce projet je
passe à la question financière et aux
plans de relance
il n'y a pas de doute que ce projet
s'inscrit bien dans le pacte européen
le green deal que dans les choix qui
sont faits actuellement par l'europe
pour accélérer la politique de lutte
contre le changement climatique ou en
tout cas de transition écologique de
l'europe qui semble se trouve tout cas
de plus en plus consensuel et
personnellement je m'en réjouis la crise
soit 12 accélère sans doute cette prise
de conscience et il me semble que notre
projet s'inscrit bien dans ses objectifs
que l'europe est en train de
d'afficher de manière plus volontariste
de réduction des gaz à effet de serre et
de progression vers toutes les
politiques qui permettent d'améliorer la
résilience de notre territoire par
rapport aux changements climatiques donc
il me semble qu'on est bien dans ce
cadre là et c'est aussi pour ça que en
ce moment en tout cas la commission
insiste pour que non seulement on n'est
pas de doute sur notre projet mais même
qu'on fasse tout pour ne pas le retarder
et donc si tu as raison pour laquelle
pour l'instant tout cas l'objectif reste
bien 2030 pour que ce projet participe
bien à la politique européenne
d'amélioration écologique de l'ensemble
de l'itinéraire
alors effectivement nous sommes dans le
plan de relance français nous sommes
dans le tendre lançant ses 200 millions
d'euros ont été apportées ça n'est
qu'une petite partie de l'ensemble
enfin en tout cas l'état a voulu mettre
une partie de plaisir dans le projet
dans le cadre du plan de relance est
donc à ce à travers sa blessure nous
inscrivons aussi dans la politique
européenne de relance économique alors
les ports français
j'ai une sensibilité une affection
particulière pour marseille puisque si
tôt que j'ai travaillé sept ans voilà
est-ce que ce projet est défavorable aux
ports français jeu franchement je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse le dire un la
desserte de marseille
elle est en compétition avec les ports
du nord l'axé nord-sud est très
important pour elle je ne vois pas
pourquoi dans la compétition avec les
ports italiens par exemple marseille
seraient pénalisés enfin franchement le
port de marseille et des capacités
absolument remarquable les entreprises
qui marchent ils sont en train je trouve
du bien progressé sur le plan du climat
général du port sans qu'on parle un peu
moins des difficultés marseillaise ça va
durer et donc moi j'ai tout à fait
confiance qu'ils sont capables de se
battre alors bon la sphère chinoise du
site à liens ont eu pendant un moment
ils ont fait les yeux doux à la chine
c'était avant la crise avec la fameuse
route de la soie et donc on a eu tout un
discours auquel les chinois ouvre grand
la porte ils payèrent à la fois du
financement et donc et du soutien aux
grands trafics internationaux
là dessus moi j'étais jeune mes
collègues italiens un peu plus réservés
je me sentais pas investi d'une mission
permettant d'accueillir plus facilement
les trafics chellois sur nos territoires
et je me sens encore moins cette mission
je peux dire que depuis quelques mois
donc voilà je laisse la chine là où elle
est et je me dis que notre projet a déjà
pas mal de choses à faire dans nos
territoires et que ça vaut la peine
savoie la peine de le faire alors les
voies d'accès et dijon modane alors
l'état ministères a dit mais en
attendant qu'on aménage des voies
d'accès on pourrait améliorer l' axe
dijon qui va vers toujours des jours
modane
si j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour cet
hiver et magnifique qui les arrange le
lac du bourget c'est un superbe endroit
que vous connaissez sûrement
est ce qu'on peut faire passer plus de
trains par là pour papa mais on n'est
pas dans le corridor
alors on peut faire certainement des
chaussures des gens mais notre sujet à
nous c'est d'être sur le corridor
méditerranée c'est d'aller à lyon perd
aussi de descendre vers l'espagne voilà
donc l'europe évidemment ces demandes et
de qu'on parlait là alors moi je me
prononce pas sur l'intérêt d'améliorer
dijon ce que je dis c'est que ce n'est
pas la solution ça résout pas le
problème de lyon ça permet à quelques
tracks peut-être de partir vers dijon
d'aller vers lyon mais si vous faites ça
vous réservez pas le problème pour les
en espagne donc je jeu pourquoi pas mais
ça peut pas être la solution
d'ailleurs je crois que là-dessus les
choses ont évolué on peut faire des
travaux d'amélioration de l'accès sur
dijon mais il faut travailler sur le
corridor qui va à lyon et donc on
n'échappera pas à affronter les gros
problèmes aux lyonnais vous connaissez
mieux que moi le contournement de lyon a
menacé de lyon la gare de la part-dieu
le sujet énorme de lyon qu'il faut je
pense prendre à bras le corps on
n'échappera pas un effort important
d'investissement pour traiter le néo
lyonnais est un sujet difficile mais
qu'il faut prendre en compte réellement
alors du coup l'europe évidemment d'y
rester sur leur faim tout caste soutenez
le corridor je mets de l'argent
l'acte d'exécution dans le langage
bruxellois qui consiste à faire en sorte
que l'europe intervient dans un rôle de
rassemblement de coordination entre la
france et l'italie
nous on le voit d'un bon oeil alors
évidemment la france divin que chacun
reste un peu chez soi les accès français
c'est pour la france et excite d'alias
et pour l'italie
fin de nos amis italiens il souhaite
parler aussi des accès français parce
que l'itinéraire il est unique voit pas
le couper en morceaux de pied meilleure
coordination des trois italie français
et nous entre les deux avec bruxelles je
crois que c'est souhaitable et le fait
que l'europe mette des moyens financiers
on va quand même pas le regretter
quand moi personnellement je l'accueille
volontiers ce qui fait que la france
pour le tunnel ne finance que 25% du
total
alors là aussi sur la question de la
rentabilité est ce qu'on parle de la
rentabilité économique est là le rempart
la question des trafics ou est ce qu'on
dit est ce qu'il ya pas un intérêt pour
la france en payant 25 % de cet ouvrage
d'avoir un équipement de transport
ferroviaire fret des soirs de grande
dimension de prendre capacités
européennes est ce que ça vaut pas la
peine de profiter si je puis dire de cet
investissement qui reste pour la france
tout de même d'un montant relativement
raisonnable puisque on en paye 25% voilà
tout cas c'est incontestablement une
volonté européenne qui est durable qui
date depuis 30 ans et les gouvernements
se sont succédé les majorités se sont
succédé et l'europe n'a pas changé d'un
pouce sur ce sujet elle est toujours sur
la même ligne même si je vais donner la
parole à monsieur fernique puis à
monsieur de tabarot monsieur verveine
monsieur fermi oui merci j'étais très
intéressé par votre référence à
l'exemple suisse parce que je crois
qu'effectivement les suisses ont montré
de façon éclairante la nécessité d'une
politique globale en la matière ne sont
pas contentés de de lancer la
construction de leur ensemble de tunnel
de base mais donc à partir de leur
référendum de 92 raison fixer
politiquement vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
des suisses le nombre maximal de deux
poids lourds acceptable on les traverse
et transalpine ils sont vraiment donné
les moyens de faire bouger le curseur
avant la mise en service des tunnels le
curseur modal on vous l'avait dit en
amenant le ferroviaire à 60%
ç'a été la redevance poids lourds liée à
la prestation
ep l'éco-redevance ça a été aussi de se
donner les moyens de d'utiliser à plein
régime
la ligne ferroviaire historique
à peu près le même profil que la nôtre
est alors que pour nous j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une une erreur de
priorisation qui risquent passez moi
l'expression mais de le faire que quand
notre tunnel de base à acheter on risque
d'avoir une cathédrale dans le désert
c'est à dire sans avoir fait bouger
fortement en s'en donnant les moyens
le curseur modal 1
on connaît les moyens d'y arriver les
suisses ou allemands nous le montrer et
et si on n'arrive pas effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit à travailler aussi
sur les accès au tunnel ne lyonnais
chambéry voilà ma question
merci monsieur fernique mais c'est à
barreaux oui monsieur le président
monsieur le président ne ne prenez pas
mal ma question et l'interpréter pas mal
parce que je suis favorable au projet et
puis dans ma région j'ai un tunnel
également franco italien alors plus
petit qu est le tunnel de tende que vous
connaissez probablement et les questions
environnementales les questions de coût
les questions de probité
il est question de dialogue entre les
français les italiens on connaît plutôt
plutôt bien et on sait que c'est pas
toujours simple quinze années de retard
pour votre projet on en a presque tout
autant pour le note mais moi j'aimerais
revenir sur les changements politiques
permanent que vous subissez notamment du
côté italien on parlait de la ministre
des transports tout à l'heure je crois
savoir qu'elle n'est plus en poste et
qu'il n'y a plus de ministre des
transports ce moment en italie même plus
de gouvernement j'aimerais parler aussi
des changements de positions en france
c'est un projet qui était fortement
porté à l'origine par les écologistes
qui est plutôt logique par rapport à
l'effort qui est fait en matière de fret
ferroviaire et quand je vois aujourd'hui
la position défavorable nouveau maire de
lyon j'ai du mal à comprendre ces
changements de deux positions et je
pense que pour vous c'est pas simple
dans les différentes discussions
bilatérales et européennes que vous
pouvez abo
par rapport à ça moi je me pose la
question vous avez en partie répondu
mais les collègues sont de cet avis
aussi on est un peu inquiet de savoir si
un projet qui est globalement un projet
des années 90 est-ce qu'il est toujours
adaptée en termes de mobilité aux
évolutions énorme qu'on a connus ces
dernières années et et revient la
question accrue des accès vous en avez
en partie par les enfin pour eux pour re
siéger assez régulièrement sur le
corridor européen sud ce fameux corridor
qui d'ailleurs a été prolongée entre
gênes et marseille en a obtenu avec le
président mais au lieu de le faire et ça
répond en partie à la question du du
port de marseille et de la concurrence
entre ces deux ports moi j'ai eu
l'impression à chaque fois que je me
suis rendu à bruxelles sur ces questions
que c'est surtout l'europe qu'ils
souhaitent et ce projet et je trouvais
les états français et italiens un peu en
retrait par rapport à ça on avait même
l'impression que c'était l'europe qui
forçait la main en disant il n'y a pas
de retour possible en arrière par
rapport à la manière et à l'avancée du
projet donc je souhaitais simplement
vous puissiez nous rassurer sur ses
différents bois et ses différentes
interrogations
merci philippe monsieur viersen il a
quitté bon ben je vous propose de
répondre c'était de questions alors
c'est sûr c'est sur ces aspects
politiques c'est vrai qu' on est parfois
comment dire un peu troublé voir
embarrassé quand il ya des évolutions
politiques qui conduisent à des
changements ou des questionnements voire
des critiques
je dois vous dire je suis très troublé
pour ma part par la position on va dire
des milieux où des partis ou les
mouvements écologiques qui ont été dans
un premier temps favorable au projet
parce qu'ils y ont pris en compte si je
veux dire la preda priorités
environnementales au port modal
protection des alpes convention alpine
enfin voilà donc c'était quand même bien
la base et puis ce changement de
deux positions qui maintenant les
conduit à s'y opposer
et pourquoi je suis enfin ce changement
me troublent profondément je vous parle
encore très très librement parce que ce
qui est la motivation principale du
projet report modal protection
d'environnement est combattu par ceux
qui les défendent
et la raison pour laquelle il plaide
cela c'est qu'ils disent que la voie
actuelle permet de faire la faire et je
ne n'arrive pas nous n'arrivons pas à
parler de ça de manière objective
c'est à dire on peut ou ne peut pas
faire passer les trains sur la ligne ça
passe ou ça passe pas et donc ce qui
devrait être une discussion de gens de
compétences rationnelle non pas dans
l'idéologie ou où la sensibilité mais
dans une analyse objective qui peut être
vérifiée expertise et en fait nous
n'avons pas nous pas sur ceux sur ce
terrain et donc on reste dans ce
malentendu fondamental ce que vous
faites se sert à rien puisqu'elle est
une actuelle permet de le faire voilà et
voilà bien en somme large sais pas si un
jour on pourra se réconcilier alors
qu'on devrait être moindre
sur la même ligne de préoccupations
environnementales nous nous battons si
je peux dire sur cette raison là alors
je suis bien placé pour connaître la
liane quand j'étais à l'appel j'ai fait
les travaux d'aménagement du tunnel et
donc je sais ce qu'il peut faire et pas
faire et je ne suis pas un spécialiste
il ya des cheminots plus compétents que
moi il ya des il ya des gens qui peuvent
le dire mieux que moi
eh bien ça ne change pas cette position
de blocage alors sur les autres aspects
côté italien
alors la politique italienne et explosa
c'est assez subtil
en fait il y a une grande volonté
d'abord de l'italie du nord des milieux
économiques des milieux politiques très
largement partagée sauf un mouvement
très fort très puissants pendant un
moment en tout cas qui s'appelle le
mouvement 5 étoiles qui lui s'est mis
dans l'opposition en s'appuyant sur la
contestation de la vallée il faut bien
voir que l'italie a commis le pense une
erreur je leur dis ça j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié c'est que quand on a lancé le
projet ils n'ont pas pris de précautions
pour discuter avec le territoire sur le
tracé ils ont fait le tracé de manière
technocratique et quand le tracé a été
présentée à laval
et il a donné lieu à une opposition
totale un rejet total de toute la vallée
qui ne voulait pas de ce projet qui
avait déjà eu trop de près et il ya eu
de débat public a pas eu ce que nous
connaissons nous en terme de dialogue ou
de confrontation avec le territoire donc
rejet total obligations violent
obligation de reprendre le projet de le
refaire le mouvement 5 étoiles est resté
ensuite sur cette ligne d'opposition
totale
et puis il ya eu ensuite l'alliance avec
la ligue dans le gouvernement comptait
dans lesquels dans l'accord de
gouvernement italien l'opposition de
cinq étoiles n'a pas changé mais ça n'a
pas empêché que le projet continue
voilà donc on t a réussi à trouver un
point d'équilibré opposition de 5
étoiles mais on a pu continuer le projet
donc le problème n'a pas été arrêté
s'était cependant une période difficile
et aujourd'hui dans les négociations
actuelles que vous suivez je pense du
gouvernement italien avec rallye il ya
en fait je pense maintenant un assez
large consensus chez l'as bages
italienne en tout cas la basse politique
italienne est assez globalement
favorables alors c'est vrai cela dit
qu'il ya eu cette opposition très
violente partiel mais très violente en
italie et en france on a toujours fait
avancer le projet mais on peut pas dire
qu'on ait eu une volonté farouche ni une
expression d'un très très grand
dynamisme et sur ce projet c'est un
projet assez souvent a été poussé au
niveau de l'elysée à je veux dire des
choses comme le sont par les prises en
république successifs pour des raisons
variées en europe des régions
européennes voilà de rapprochement
stratégique et politique franco italien
l'italie le voulait et du coup accepté
de payer plus cher la france n'était pas
particulièrement demandeuse était pas
vraiment content mais pas non plus
vraiment pour et comme l'europe poussée
aussi finalement le mouvement a été créé
comme ça alors nous dans cette
affaire-là si vous voulez on n'est pas
sur le terrain politique on doit
respecter ses objectifs que de fixed nos
autorités il sent les autorités
publiques des deux états et de leurs
nous inscrivons émotif il est de nature
et l'origine fonctionnaires
mon travail c'est de faire ça et donc de
fournir aux états des éléments les plus
exacte possible les plus compétents
possible pour que les hommes et femmes
politiques prennent leurs décisions et
nous ensuite tout faisant le travail qui
nous demande de faire nous avons dans ce
contexte où vous me posiez la question
d'évolution parfois un peu de
traitements voire de péripéties et aux
politiques nous avons réussi à tenir ce
cap le plus loyalement possible en cas
on l'a bien voulu le le reconnaître nos
collègues collègues italiens électorale
et renouvellant c'est dans ses fonctions
donc nous avons réussi dans ces périodes
parfois difficiles à maintenir notre
travail dans cette société donc comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure
binational dans lequel nous avons je
crois de bonne de bonnes compétences
mais fondamentalement vous avez raison
de dire que ce projet a tenu dans
l'histoire dans le temps parce que
l'europe y tient elle croit qu'il faut
faire ce réseau ferroviaire européen à
grande dimension et à grande capacité
elle croit que ce projet doit se faire
pour permettre à ce corridor sud de
fonctionner globalement dans as raison
il ya cette grande majorité européenne
cette volonté européenne de le faire moi
j'observe quand même que cette volonté
de l'europe par ailleurs critiquables et
critiquées par un certain nombre de
personnes a permis quand même de faire
bousculer un peu des résistances
culturelles franco française je je je
pense par exemple que les français sont
tous passionnés par les transports de
voyageurs
mais pas beaucoup passionné par le
transport de marchandises et c'est
peut-être parce qu'on a mis un peu
d'europe dans tout ça qu'on a finalement
quand même fait des choses pour
lesquelles je vous parle très librement
excusez moi me suis présenté me dire que
je suis plus du tout dans mon rôle mais
je vois là je pense je me dis que car la
france parfois où les français qui ont
par ailleurs beaucoup de qualités n'ont
pas manifesté beaucoup d'intérêt moi je
vous assure j'ai souvenir car elles ont
fait les frais quand je dis que la corde
et un une certaine priorité aux trains
de marchandises si on voulait qu'ils
roulent on me disait que j'étais c'était
une histoire de technocrates qui vous et
me rendais pas compte que c'était pas ça
le problème des gens alors c'est vrai
que quand vous êtes en ile-de-france le
problème c'est d'avoir des rer qui
marche je m'appelle discussions avec le
président russe aux brides régions du
mali qui trouvait que je fasse de vos
trains de marchandises qui peuvent pas
contourner paris moi ça m'intéresse
matelassé que les voyageurs puissent
prendre le revers du présent c'est
parfaitement normal
vous défendiez cette position en tant
président de région il faut que les gens
puissent arriver chez eux des mois au
niveau national si des trains de
marchandises ne peuvent pas traverser au
contourner paris et bien il y aura pas
de trains de marchandises en france
voilà donc il faut quand même trouver
des points de compromis ou de
compatibilité entre cette urgence
française de s'occuper des voyageurs et
dieu sait qu'il faut continuer à le
faire on n'est pas encore au bout et
puis le fait qu'il faut quand même
arriver à faire passer des trains sur le
territoire merci monsieur la paroisse
monsieur bigot et ensuite à monsieur
jacques 1 voilà merci monsieur
président merci pour cette présentation
vous nous avez indiqué que l'europe
soutenait ce projet qui était la
condition de sa réussite voyant même
pouvant augmenter le financement et vous
avez indiqué qu'il y avait neuf sion en
europe qui étaient conservés et qui
faisaient partie d'une volonté politique
de développer le fret ferroviaire
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure mon
collègue monsieur fernique il semblerait
que deux à l'intérieur de nos frontières
en france on n'ait pas suivi au niveau
des infrastructures la possibilité de
desservir c'est l'accès à ce tunnel
selon vous dans quel délai peut-on
espérer que la fluidité du trafic puisse
concerner les accès côté français tout
au moins sur cette infrastructure qui
est effectivement très importante demain
pour le l'aménagement du je dirais même
de l'europe merci merci je vais aller
dans le même sens que mon collègue joël
dans ce projet qui est véritablement
politique la rationalité économique
strictes peut-être questionnez vous ne
m'avez pas rassuré sur un des points de
fragilité énorme du projet qui concerne
l'accès français au tunnel et vous avez
bien dit à un de manière
j'allais dire subtilement vous avez dit
de manière sombre et peut-être que faire
entrer un million de camions dans le
tunnel qui est l'objectif
environnemental écologique qu'on doit
soutenir le tunnel est quasi fait
maintenant et bien nécessitera des
réseaux amont et aval de qualité est là
dessus vraiment une fragilité
vous avez évoqué la suisse et
j'inviterai notre commission à recevoir
éventuellement une délégation suisse
parce que le système suisse et
passionnant jacques fernique la la dcri
ils ont la visibilité
ils ont des ressources affectées et
votre homologue enfin le directeur
général adjoint du min
suisse m'avait fait cette remarque
amusée c'est un franco suisse 10 ans
mais ça coûte beaucoup moins cher vous
le direz à vos collègues d'avoir des
ressources affectées
une programmation à 15 ans ont fait
beaucoup moins de bêtises que de faire
du yo yo des allers et retours et en
plus ils ont une obligation c'est ça va
être ma question monsieur du mesnil en
même temps que la fragilité des
financements pour les accès français en
tout cas l'ampleur des rénovations qui
seront faites en amont on a évoqué je
veux nécessité de faire quasiment
jusqu'à jusqu'à dijon
y aura-t-il nécessité d'une obligation
de pour les camions d'emprunter dans des
conditions acceptables puisqu'il y à
d'autres accès possible pour le fret de
longues distances
une obligation d'emprunter en transport
combiné je suis également dans la
commission transport de marchandises et
autant effectivement certains
interlocuteurs questionne le fret
ferroviaire
au global mais il a ses champs de
pertinence et notamment dans la longue
distance et tout le monde nous le dit
donc demain quelqu'un qui viendra
d'amsterdam pour aller en italie
est-ce qu'il sera obligé d'emprunter une
autoroute ferroviaire qui passera par
notamment celui ans tu vois je vous
remercie
je vais donner la parole et didier
mandelli monsieur le président voilà mon
intervention fait suite à un grand
nombre de questions
évidemment toute légitime basse et j'ai
pas de questions c'est simplement un
témoignage parce que je pense qu'on
oublie souvent j'ai eu la chance dans le
cadre de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités dont j'étais le rapporteur de
de découvrir ce chantier jeudi chantier
parce que c'est extraordinaire et je
voudrais qu'on rappelle simplement que
c'est un des plus grands chantiers du
siècle par sa durée par par les volumes
et par le nombre de l'entreprise et de
personnels engagés
moi j'ai eu cette chance de découvrir
avec jean pierre vial à ce moment-là ce
chantier avec d'autres
et je voudrais qu'on n'oublie pas que
c'est avant tout comment pensent par
ailleurs une prouesse technologique
assez exceptionnel avec des qui traduit
à la fois le niveau technique de nos
entreprises de nos ingénieurs de nos
techniciens et je crois qu'on prend un
très fier et moi je souhaitais qu'on
puisse éventuellement visité le chantier
j'ai eu la chance de le découvrir au
meilleur moment choisir mais je vois là
je voulais qu'on le rappelle parce qu'on
on a quelquefois tendance à l'oublier
c'est une belle belle réalisation par
son ampleur et au niveau d'engagement de
ses personnels merci je vous laisse
répondre à un autre collègue monsieur le
président oui mais je commence par vous
remercier de ce témoignage j'y suis très
sensible et je confirme effectivement
cette invitation de votre délégation de
notre commission c'est vrai que nous
constatons que lorsque les personnes
viennent voir le chantier
ils n'ont pas la même appréciation sur
le projet d'abord parce qu'ils voient
que ça commence à ressembler un tunnel
c'est à dire que c'est pas du fond de la
boue qu'on remue est aussi un oral que
j'ai dit m
esthétiquement il ya quelque chose
d'assez bon voilà on a pris des des
photos voilà donc j'ai et puis
techniquement on a des entreprises
européennes en tout cas française
italienne et suisse qui sont absolument
qu'ils font des prouesses absolument
remarquable quand vous voyez deux
tunneliers qui avance et qui est qui
percute la la montagne qui fait face à
des difficultés incroyables des choses à
une venue d'eau qu'on n'avait pas prévu
une partie plus dur au contraire donc
c'est vraiment absolument remarquable et
c'est vraiment à l'échelle mondiale
raison merci de le dire parce que je
pense que le dommage s'adresse
principalement aux entreprises assez
d'entreprises iace personnels qui font
un travail qui n'est pas toujours facile
parce que passer ses terres en suivant
au fond du tunnel c'est c'est parfois
dur qu'en ce moment depuis quelques mois
ils font face à la crise sanitaire comme
tout le monde et non pas qu'ils
comparent été les chantiers ils ont pris
des dispositions extrêmement rigoureuse
tout à fait remarquable qui ont permis
aux chantiers se dérouler sentiers de
l'accident donc le voilà merci de ce
témoignage parce qu'effectivement je
pense qu'il le méritait
il ya une année d une intelligence si je
peux dire des entreprises là une
recherche qui est faite d'innovations
qui est vraiment à l'échelle mondiale
est tout à fait remarquable alors sur le
2 2 points complémentaires sur le
calendrier des accès et puis sur la
fragilité du financement alors sur le
calendrier désaxé côté italie le projet
est prêt il est dans le plan de relance
est italien et il n'y a pas de
difficulté ils l'ont phase est dans un
premier temps il examina fait inexistant
jusqu'à turin c'est beaucoup plus proche
le juge donc c'est pas difficile à faire
donc un parti italien est en ordre le
projet est prêt et le financement va
être assurée d'entendre dans ces
italiens très largement soutenue par
l'europe
côté français donc côté français les
choses ont été relancée il ya il ya un
peu plus de deux ans et donc il ya
aujourd'hui un travail qui est fait par
sncf réseau puisqu'on est sur leur
domaine de compétence pour reprendre le
projet que nous avions jeudi nous parce
que c'était réfléchi à ce moment là que
nous avions préparé un projet d'accès
qui était sans doute généreux en tout
cas su abondant puisqu'il y avait deux
lignes nouvelles
il pour le fret une fois les voyageurs
qui allait de lyon jusqu'à saint jean de
maurienne
ce projet donc a été déjà eu des huées
donc il a cheminé ans et sa concertation
il a été attaqué conseil d'état qu'il a
malgré tout à prouver donc il est prêt
sauf que ce projet est trop coûteux
parce que faire deux lignes nouvelles
c'est c'est quelque chose de trop
importante donc le ministre mystère a
décidé de créer donc une commission de
travail présidé par le préfet qui
consiste à reprendre le projet qui était
mis à développer et à le simplifier pour
qu'ils aient au moins une première phase
qui permettent d'assurer la continuité
trafic au moment de l'ouverture du
tunnel donc à l'horizon 2030 et que donc
on le fasse par étapes mais avec une
première étape qui est dans le corridor
donc tu vas vers lyon et qui permet en
2030 d'assurer l'écoulement normal du
trafic donc il ya deux scénarios qui ont
été adoptés qui ont été approfondis donc
on a on a deux itinéraires possibles et
l'année prochaine à décision doit être
prise de retenir l'un des deux dans le
cadre de la dlp lorcy
cet objectif est atteint c'est pas mal
parce que puisque les encadrent des
huées
on a déjà franchi l'étape très important
qui est d'avoir la vue et à ce moment là
on reste sur un calendrier qui peut être
compatible avec l'horizon 2030 2032
donc si on fait ça si l'année prochaine
on décide
lequel de ces deux scénarios alors je le
choix n'est pas facile je pour les gens
de la région la laisser la terre la
région il dit parce que je peux dire le
choix des barrages il parce qu'il y en a
qui est vraiment très priorité fret et
qui n'améliore pas beaucoup de choses
pour les voyageurs dans un premier temps
et donc oui il ya un arbitrage à faire
voilà est-ce que je mets le paquet sur
le fret pourraient être prêts aux angles
en 2030
ou est ce que quand même je tarde pas
aussi à dire à chambéry et annecy coup à
grenoble que l'on peut améliorer les
choses pour donc en tout cas je pense
que la situation s'est pas mal rétabli
et aujourd'hui ça reste possible d'être
cohérent en terme de calendrier avec
l'horizon 2030
il faut que d'ici l'année prochaine le
choix soit fait l'un des scénarios
et puis ensuite on aille de l'avant
alors sur la fragilité des financements
c'est vrai que ça n'est il vaudrait
mieux pour un projet qui dure autant de
temps une fois qu'on l'a commencée en
soirée assurée d'avoir des financements
ce serait mieux mais c'est pas vraiment
le cas alors qu'est-ce que nous avons
sur la table
ben finalement le seul qui assure un
financement pluriannuel c'est l'italie
l'italie a voté le financement du réel
de 80% de sa part 35 % du total
ils ont voté au parlement c'est à
l'époque du gouvernement si ils ont fait
voter un budget pluriannuel pour ce
projet côté france nous sommes avec la
fit vous connaissez bien nos branches et
donc nous sommes dépendants d'un vote
annuel
et donc nous avons un problème à
renouveler tous les ans d'assurer le
financement de l'année qui vient alors
nous avons l'engagement politique de
l'état qui nous autorise à signer les
marchés
mais en termes financiers nous avons la
dépendance du vote annuel pour la fille
il ya un travail a été fait pour
proposer des financements d'une autre
nature et notamment l'appel à l'origine
est donc prélèvements sur les trafics
routier et partie montage financier avec
un emprunt qui allez y à 34 ans n'a pas
été acceptée
la discussion n'est pas des n'est pas
définitivement close parce que les
problèmes d'endettement sont en train
d'évoluer
le respect des critères d'endettement
sont peut-être en train d'être peut-être
en train d'être considérés donc
peut-être que le sujet de la dette
et voyez bien que ne pas assurer un
financement par un emprunt sur un projet
qui va durer et plus de 50 ans et donc
s'obliger à le payer en 12 ans alors
qu'on pourrait le payer en 50 ans où la
présence est peut-être un peu dommage
donc le sujet reste ouvert côté france
pour l'instant il faut que chaque année
la fille tu nous donnes les crédits qui
vont bien jusqu'à ces derniers temps
c'était des crédits relativement modeste
médard en 2000 21 22 23
on va monter à des sommes nettement plus
importante donc il va falloir que la fit
arriva à gérer cette difficulté nous
n'avons pas d'inquiétude particulière
mais on peut pas dire qu'on ait un
financement structuré purée annuel est
assurée on est un peu côté bruxelles
s'est pas beaucoup mieux
on avait un financement assuré jusqu'en
2021 avait été prolongé en 2022 et nous
allons commencer maintenant à une
discussion pour les années qui viennent
mais on nous dit à bruxelles que des
parents ont pensé avoir un contrat pour
sept ans il est question de le ramener à
3 ans qui veut dire qu'on aura pas non
plus de la part de bruxelles
un montant assuré pour aller jusqu'au
bout avec les clés de financement je
vous ai indiqué voilà donc voilà un
projet c'est de vous parler une
fragilité moi j'ai pas de doute que la
volonté là pas aller jusqu'au bout on
peut pas dire qu'on ait mis en place les
instruments de financement pluriannuel
ce tueur et et durable donc on chemine
les puisque périodiquement on remet ça
sur la table et il faut à chaque fois
discuter les conditions et les modalités
voit vraiment une faiblesse quand même
que nous avons je pense que vous avez
raison de le signaler et quant à la
régulation et à l'exemple suisse oui je
pense que l'idée qui avait évoqué ça
peut rappeler que monsieur destot et
c'est bouvard avait travaillé ensemble
pour faire une proposition de de montage
dans lequel il y avait un emprunt qui
était en particulier gagées par des
recettes venant des axes autoroutiers
donc c'est ce que les suisses ont fait
avec un prélèvement sur les trafics
routier alors que le sujet est sensible
il est délicat
il avait démontré que
on pouvait faire un prélèvement extra
sur un territoire très large y compris
vintimille
avec donc un très très grand nombre de
camions sur lequel vous pouviez faire un
prélèvement du coup assez modérée et
donc il avait démontré que ce n'était
pas c'est pas impossible et bruxelles
voyez ça d'un plutôt d'un bon oeil donc
le sujet je pense n'est pas n'est pas
définitivement abandonné mais pour
l'instant en tout cas il fait pas
l'objet d'une proposition élaborée et
construit donc je continue à penser qu'
il faut vraiment jouer sur les deux je
pense que vous avez raison de le dire
est ce qu est ce qu il faut interdire le
trafic de camions je pense qu'il faut en
tout cas les réguler c'est à dire vous
avez déjà tout à une catégorie le camion
vous pouvez interdire c'est tout ce
qu'ils transportent des marchandises
dangereuses ceux qui ont des normes
environnementales qui sont inadaptées
donc vous pouvez déjà restreindre un peu
le lac contraindre un peu le trafic
et puis vous avez la tarification ce qui
est sûr c'est que quand vous faites
comme moi je vais vous circuler sur les
autoroutes et vous voyez des camions qui
sont immatriculés en lituanie qui vont
être portugal la volonté de l'europe
c'est ça il faut le supprimer
un camion qui fait en europe un parcours
supérieur mettions à 1000 km lire par
ailleurs c'est de la france ça doit
disparaître voilà et moi je lui dis
quelquefois je vois six camions qui
travaillaient sur l'a10 par exemple
c'était avant dix essais espagnols les
portugais les espagnols ils sont à côté
de chez nous moi je ne prends pas normal
qu'ils rentrent chez eux aussi pour
travailler je ne dis pas qu'il faut les
refuser mais ce qui me choque c'est de
voir des camions qui traversent l'europe
entière et c'est ça ce que l'europe veut
supprimer
et je pense que si on le veut on a quand
même suffisamment d'arguments s'agit pas
de faire des obstacles à tout le monde
il gênait tous les routiers c'est pas du
tout ça à une partie du trafic intra
européen qui devrait passer je viens ben
monsieur dumesnil merci merci monsieur
le président pour pour la clarté de vos
propos merci effectivement pour 7 pour
cet échange pour cet échange
et puis je tiens à vous dire mes chers
collègues que sur ordinateur avec toi tu
veux pas si vas-y vas-y vas-y
désolé désolé
aujourd'hui sa part il ya il ya un souci
président en tout cas merci déjà pour
l'ensemble des éléments de réponse vous
a pu apporter au regard de l'ampleur de
ce projet on a du mal aujourd'hui à
visualiser la stratégie logistique qui
devrait se mettre en place pour essayer
d'optimiser justement cet ouvrage on a
le sentiment que c'est la logique du
marché qui est de toute façon va
s'appliquer et qu'il n'a pas une vision
anticipé pour essayer d'optimiser au
mieux les flux vers cet ouvrage est ce
que vous pourriez me donnait des
éléments d'éventuellement d'appréciation
par rapport à ce sujet sur les liaisons
aériennes
on voit bien que des positionnements
politiques aujourd'hui on pourrait
penser que demain
certaines liaisons aériennes pourraient
être supprimés pour transférer le trafic
sur la liaison est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un débat qui est d'ores et
déjà ouvert pour pouvoir anticiper au
mieux ce transfert enfin vous l'avez
évoqué ça fait partie d'un débat
politique est très nourris sur lequel il
ya toujours une difficulté pour
objectiver notamment sur ce qu'on
appelle l'impact environnemental de ce
type de projet est ce que ce débat est
mort né ou est-ce qu'il faut essayer de
nourrir pour essayer d'amener des
éléments qui amène à une réflexion la
plus objective possible en termes
d'évaluation environnementale et de fait
comme c'est un projet emblématique au
niveau européen et puis comme ça a été
soulignée au niveau mondial cette
évaluation environnementale de qualité
permettrait justement d'apporter en
termes de méthodes des clés de lecture
qui permettraient d'éclairer également
le débat politique qu'en pensez vous
vous avez gardé pour la fin la redoute
en dire à vos mais je rêve beaucoup de
modestie parce qu'en fait la vérité des
op à l'élargissement peut-être d'autres
intervenants que comme moi parce que ce
sont de très bonnes questions
l'optimisation l'altix uv c'est sûr que
les flux de marchandises évolué parce
que les marchés évoluent se cachaient
ceux qui vendent
on a parlé de la chine en a parlé du
retour au pays donc on voit bien qu'on
n'est pas sûr donné
qui fusillait elle va évoluer la crise
va sans doute obliger aussi a évolué je
pense pour ma part que j'espère en tout
cas que on va calmer un peu la mobilité
parce qu'elle était sans doute emballé
excessive
je pense qu'elles étaient excessives la
mobilité mondiale et qu'on va sans doute
chercher un point d'équilibré
non pas pour en empêcher les
marchandises circulent et mais peut-être
pour en faire un peu moins réussie les
exemples on prenait un vêtement dont une
partie était fait dans un pays des
boutons un deuxième pays il est fils
d'un troisième donc l'économie sans
doute est parti dans un emballement qui
entraîne une mobilité très forte et une
logistique débridée c'est à dire dans
lequel j'ai tiré c'était la fuite en
avant de tous les moyens pour que soient
le moins cher possible et on a vu à quoi
ça pouvait le mener sur le plan
environnemental je pense que la crise et
dans la prise de conscience et dans
j'espère en tout cas que on va mieux
réguler la logistique internationale et
non pas figer les choses pour qu'on
consomme sur place et qu'on n'achète
plus rien à l'étranger mais peut-être
pour réduire l'emballement dans lequel
on s'est trouvés elle reste que la
logistique
dans ces conditions a cheminé vers un
optimum et elle va progresser je pense
qu'il faut trouver une combinaison des
lois du marché parce que je pense qu on
reste quand même dans une économie de
marché dans lequel il ya une certaine
liberté d'acheter et de vendre il ya de
la liberté c'est sûr mais qui cette
liberté doit être régulée c'est à dire
que notamment par des par une offre de
qualité on a parlé du ferroviaire si
vous avez des trains qui marche bien ça
devient attractif
ensuite par de la régulation économique
c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas normal que
des déplacements ne coûte rien et des
bateaux qui finalement fixé les
transports de conteneurs sur la chine à
des prix défiant toute concurrence
ça finit par faire des choses qui sont
ils n'ont plus de sens donc il faut
donner aux choses leur véritable valeur
et s'il ya un transport qui coûte parce
qu'il produit la pollution c'est le cas
d'un camion il faut qu'il faut qu'il le
paye et d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc je pense qu'il faut combiner la
liberté du marché de la logistique avec
delà de l'offre de qualité ça c'est
notamment des questions
d'infrastructures et avec de la
régulation moyennant quoi je pense que
les choses peuvent se redresser et qu'il
y à des optimisations possibles mais ça
vient pas forcément tout seul en tout
cas le laisser faire ne conduit pas
l'optimisation ça je pense que la crise
vient de me le montrer il faut que les
autorités compétentes à bonne échelle
national européen et international
prend-ça en main comme dans beaucoup
d'autres domaines comme les marchés
financiers c'est quoi il ya certaines
ont dû beaucoup de choses encore à faire
devant nous si on veut redresser une
situation et ne pas s'enfoncer dans la
crise alors quand à l'impact
environnemental vous avez raison sien
c'est un sujet sur lequel on a je pense
bien avancé parce que il ya de plus en
plus de normes qui sont produites il ya
une surveillance administrative nous on
a par exemple 141 points de contrôle va
141 points que l'on mesure en permanence
avec des organismes publics sous le
contrô lé ministère pour mesurer la
qualité de l'eau et de l'air l'intensité
du bruit donc de bruxelles a donc cet
aspect technique de l'environnement doit
être pris en compte l'environnement ça
passe par là on peut faire des belles
paroles on peut faire des discours est
très lyrique mais il faut que la
question d'environnement passe par des
choses très concrètes et des choses
scientifique avec de la compétence de
l'expérience de la recherche donc
l'impact environnemental passe d'abord
par une maîtrise du du du chantier et je
vous assure qu'on a fait déjà beaucoup
de progrès mais peut on peut encore
faire beaucoup d'autres progrès sur je
vous donne qu'un exemple ça si vous
permettez pour pas être alors je suis
beaucoup de plomb et une chose toute
bête quand vous faites un tunnel vous
creusez vous enlever des matériaux vous
les sortez qu'est ce que vous en faites
on a enlevé 57 km de foix
toute cette marche de matériau qu'est ce
qu'on en fait alors un objectif simple
c'est que le plus possible dont les
réutilise si au lieu de faire des
carrières prendre du caillou vous prenez
les matériaux qui sort du tunnel
vous aller dans le bon sens donc notre
objectif c'est que plus de la moitié de
ces matériaux soient réutilisés soit
pour faire des matériaux de béton soit
pour faire des remblais soit pour
boucher des carrières soit pour faire du
réaménagement paysager
donc pour faire ça il faut qu'on puisse
passer d'un côté à l'autre on va sortir
des matériaux saint-jean-de-maurienne
on a besoin davantage de cailloux
l'italie faudrait aller en italie
aujourd'hui on peut pas le faire les
réglementations françaises et italiennes
ne sont pas compatibles donc on va voir
ce matériau d'un côté qu'on va stocker
dans des nombreux dépôts et on va avoir
pas suffisamment de l'autre côté on
faire des carrières
c'est absurde est ce que l'europe ça
peuvent être peut pas être aussi tout
simplement j'allais dire tout bêtement
de faire en sorte qu'il ya une vision
j'ai dit circulaire global qui est
intégré une harmonisation des règles qui
devraient être en l'occurrence les mêmes
200 en optimise la gestion de nos
matériaux comme on optimisera les
transports de marchandises et qu'on
cherche la meilleure voie et que celle
ci devrait nous conduire à optimiser
globalement comme un seul territoire et
à prendre des cailloux à côté pour les
maîtres de l'autre et non pas mettre la
frontière entre les deux pour ne pas y
arriver
donc vous voyez qu'on a acquis doivent
eux aussi comment les compliqués des
braves et je crois que finalement
lalalala rationnelle la raison le peut
l'emporter surtout si on voit l'intérêt
qu'il ya pour tous un intérêt commun à
tous de progresser sur eux sur
l'environnement abdou dans cet exemple
parce que pourront pas il m'intéresse
beaucoup et je me dis voilà moi même mon
objectif qui est de contribuer à leur
manière d'un modeste manière je vais
essayer d'obtenir sa voilà donc je suis
en train de mobiliser des les ministères
compétents pour essayer de trouver de ce
jour j'espère qu'on y arrivera je crois
qu'on y arrive
[Musique]